let me ask you this can a beta become an
alpha were you always an alpha male and
you're you know by your approximation or
did you become uh an alpha over time and
then can a beta become an alpha or do
they just destined to die that way yeah
so
um I've identified four archetypes
there's the unplugged Alpha the uh
unplug beta and then there's a plugged
in Alpha and the plugged in data
um I didn't really spend much time
considering this you know my past it's
just that through business through
dealing with my accountant through
dealing with my lawyers through going
through entrepreneur's org and sitting
in business forums I was always a guy
that they always referenced to as the
man's man they would say things like
You're an alpha male you don't put up
with [ __ ] garbage whatever you want to
call it and I just never really thought
much of it right but firstborns that
um had kind of a difficult upbringing
which I did like my parents were strict
my dad was a royal Air Force Sergeant
there was no leeway with me right if if
I didn't have the car back by 10 o'clock
at 10 01 the car phone in my dad's Honda
Accord was ringing I don't know if you
remember those old corded car phones
from 1989 but it was ringing it's like
why isn't my car home sort of thing
right so you know when you grow up
having a bit of a hard life with uh
strict boundaries
um you set high standards for yourself
you want to do more
um you know you want to please you know
your parents you wanna you wanna get
stuff out of a life sort of thing and
I've always said that you know the world
needs [ __ ] right like it's [ __ ]
that get get things done I'm not saying
[ __ ] in a sense where you know you
hurt people or that you tend to go out
of your way but you don't give a lot of
thought to pleasing or hurting people's
feelings which is a big thing you know
in today's world like I know that you'll
you know you've got the disclaimer at
the start of the video uh you know
trying to be offended sort of thing and
I never really cared about offending
people but when I sort of went through
this process of
um getting red pilled you know myself
and unplugging from society's comforting
lies that's when I sort of came up with
the notion of okay this book that I'm
writing which I ended up titling the
unplugged Alpha that is the most
appropriate title for it because when
you consume this information and you
adopt it and it becomes part of your
life you know becomes a fabric of the
man that you are you will become the
unplugged Alpha like you will become
that guy
um so you can go from you know
subscribing to comforting lies to
unsubscribing from them and putting
yourself first developing a strong
masculine frame adopting a lot of the
tenants that I talk about
um yeah you can certainly become an
unplugged Alpha but I think most guys
struggle with it and they're probably
not going to get there because the vast
majority guys I've noticed that watch my
content and I start and I started doing
this the other day on my podcast
whenever I launched it is I now open
with a disclaimer and I'll tell people
like look if you think the government
loves you if you think that women can
never Do no harm and that they're sugar
and spice and all things nice this
podcast ain't gonna be for you right
like I'm going to unplug you from these
types of comforting lies sort of thing
so most people want to believe those
comforting lies because it's easier than
you know dealing with the truth it's
easier to you know Sleepwalk through
life and just go back to sleep than it
is dealing with the the discomforting
reality of things until it's not right
yeah it's not easier and that's really
what I see because I have a lot of
friends I consider myself an alpha
although you know for the most part I've
always been
in the driver's seat of my relationships
you know which actually wasn't great
because I was bored you know
um which I think you know two people
should be equals now uh I mean meaning
like that one can't say goodbye a lot
easier than the other because that's
gonna Doom the relationship but anyway I
see I would disagree with that yeah tell
me about that let's talk about it I
don't think that men and women can be
equals in a relationship there's a
reason why there's only one steering
wheel on one set of pedals in my McLaren
because there's only one area of the car
that's set for the driver there's a
passenger seat the passenger seat has
value as well
um I get involved in a lot of
Motorsports I was just down in Baja
Mexico doing some off-road racing um and
some challenge cars and the Navigator
has very important roles extra I said on
the road they keep it they're on the
radios talking to their cars they're
looking at the navigation so you want
complementary phrases you don't want
people equal I don't think men and women
are equal I think that men and women can
compliment each other once they identify
that there's a masculine enroll and
there's a feminine role and a good woman
can compliment a man's life right if he
makes the right choice when it comes to
you know choosing women yeah I guess
where I was going with that because I
believe you know what the Bible says
that the man is the head of the
household you know he needs to be the
priest of his home and he needs all you
know the decision ultimately comes down
to you know there's different opinions
the man should make the decision and I
think that's what women want they want
to follow they're going to try to lead
and if you let them they'll resent you I
heard you talk about that 100 true but I
mean I'm talking about emotionally where
I was always in relationships with women
that I was a lot less emotionally
invested than they were which caused me
even though
I call it the shots and you know I guess
there was a certain level of security
there I was bored and I was always
looking over my shoulder wondering if I
could be happier with the next one so
now it's like I want somebody that I'm
as into them as they're into me I guess
is what I meant well you wanna like you
want to choose women that choose you
right you never want to be
in a scenario where you've got more
interest or you've or you've invested in
that relationship more than she has I
mean to try to look for parity there to
say that you know like my desire is here
and her desire is here so it's exactly
the same I think you're going to have
some difficulty one trying to evaluate
that and two maintain that I mean
there's a lot of you know complexities
that come around with that so what I
advice to guys is just make sure and
there's an entire chapter about in my
book on it on number three but make sure
you deal with women that have genuine
burning desire for you because if you
don't you could end up being her second
choice you know to say that you've both
got to have the same emotional
investment I think
I think leaves too many
um
spots open like there's too many blind
spots in it
um because you're never going to have
two people that have the same amount of
desire in each other and it changes over
time you know it's going to increase for
one person it's maybe going to go down
it's going to increase they might swap
places sort of thing but I think that if
you're a guy and you're going to choose
a woman if you want to invite a woman in
your life especially if you're talking
about something like having kids you
know getting in a scenario like that is
very high risk and low reward for a lot
of men in today's environment and it's
low risk High reward for women naturally
because they're hypergamous and they
always almost always marry across and up
on the social economic scale so for guys
because I talk mostly to guys like 90 of
my audiences guys
um for men it's make sure that you
choose women that choose you and that
she's got genuine burning desire for you
because the last thing you want to be I
get a lot of these requests and consults
from guys you don't want to be her
second choice you don't want to be the
guy that's 35 years old that wiped up to
32 year old professional with degrees on
her walls she's a a physician a lawyer
an account whatever like that but she
spent her 20s partying going to
University running through a lot of guys
and now she's ready to get right with
God and settle down right because she's
going to generally pick the beta male
she's going to pick the guy that's good
enough he's hopefully just tall enough
he's got just good enough genes but his
Future's bright because he's got a good
job he's that engineer he's got that
stem degree he's making good money so
you definitely don't want to settle for
a woman that only sees you as her second
third fourth choice you want to be her
number one choice and if you're not her
number one choice I advise guys to move
on yeah I think it's great advice
actually what you're saying and after I
watched your video I went up and I made
this my Tick Tock reel where I went up
to a whiteboard and I you're probably
familiar with this but 80 of the women
are sleeping with 20 of the men right
now
and I was like you know women say they
don't they don't want to be [ __ ] shame
they don't want to hear that you know
promiscuity is bad for them you know
down the road or whatever but I'm like
think about this eighty percent of the
women are sleeping with 20 of them what
does that mean for the 80 percent of men
they're not sleeping with anybody or if
they are it's the bottom twenty percent
right now that's going to create
problems because
the men they're sleeping with the alphas
I heard you talk about this they're
sleeping with a strong Rich whatever
athletic men that are in the top 20 but
eventually they do they want to come get
married so now they're going to come
down to the 80 and those 80 percent of
guys haven't been getting laid for a
long time and they and now they're
they're a little resentful because you
ran through all these guys up in the 20
and they were sleeping with four or five
of you at the same time or they had to
be just for the math work and now you
don't want me to have feelings about
that I'm like look I'm not I'm just the
messenger I'm not the one saying it you
know it's right or wrong I'm just saying
I can see that the writing's on the wall
and literally I was drawing it out that
it's going to create problems for you so
it's like I could totally see you know
like
how you know that that 80 like of those
men that you know betas if you want to
call them that
um they get they get screwed over in the
long run because they the women that
these 20 are sleeping with are some of
their their future wives obviously they
have to be
and they are this is what I this is I
did this debate in La
um a couple months ago where I debated
this woman that was uh
put her doctorate in sex something
sexual studies or something and she was
a proponent of of having sex before
marriage and she debated me on on NAS
debates this big YouTube channel
and I was just breaking it down I'm like
look think about it like this if if I'm
sleeping if I'm in that 20 and I'm
sleeping with multiple women
they're not my best yes maybe one of
them is my best yes but the others can't
be my best yes and but they are someone
else's best yes that's they're that was
their best yes because I think that's
what everyone is really looking for is I
want to say my best yes I want to get
someone that I don't think I could have
done any better with and that's the
person that I you know ultimately want
to be with now the only way for women to
find out if they are really someone's
best yes is to wait till marriage
because if if you are my best yes you
not having sex with me isn't going to
scare me off it will motivate me to man
up and marry you but it's not going to
make me leave you because if you're my
best yes I want I'll want it I want the
sex and I want everything that comes
with it yeah that's a very difficult
um conversation though because
I mean they've collected the data on
this and it's it's very low like the
percentage of women today that are
getting involved with a guy on a
long-term basis to raise a family uh
that were virgins it's it's tiny
percentage I think it's less than three
percent whereas you know back in the 40s
and 50s when they first started to
collect the data it was much higher it
was like well over 50 percent
um so it's like you know for guys today
you're gonna really struggle to find a
gal that hasn't been with guys before
you
um and I mean whether it's it's it's two
or it's 12 the data is pretty much the
same like as soon as they're not a
virgin
um the chances of them forming a
long-term pair bond having a healthy
long-term relationship not getting
divorce uh not being depressed uh not
going on meds and things like that they
all go up dramatically after a couple
guys
um so you've got a very very small pool
to deal with so if you're a guy looking
to find a gal that's like that you need
to be a super high value guy
um yeah and I'm not saying virgin
necessarily either but I definitely hear
what you're saying to me I guess you
know
if after a few guys the numbers play out
to be the same pretty much then that
that's the ideal I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out